لقد أجريت أيضًا محادثة مع
السيدة الأولى حول دورها كسيدة أولى
وبعض واجباتها ، بما
في ذلك عيد الميلاد في البيت الأبيض ،
أريد أن ألعبها حيث يقولون إنني
متواطئة ، فأنا
مثله أنا أؤيده.  لن أقول ما يكفي ، أنا لا
أفعل ما يكفي ،
لا ، إنها
أشياء عيد الميلاد والديكور ، لكنني
بحاجة إلى القيام بذلك بشكل صحيح ، لكن
تخيل 100 ليس لديك خيار ،
حسناً ، ثم أفعل ذلك وأقول إنني
أعمل في عيد الميلاد أه أخطط لـ  في
عيد
الميلاد وقالوا ، ماذا عن الأطفال
الذين انفصلوا عنهم ،
أعطني استراحة
حيث كانوا يقولون أي شيء عندما
فعل أوباما ذلك ، وأنا أعلم
أنني لا أستطيع الذهاب.
يحتاج إلى
متابعة العملية ومن خلال القانون ،
ولكن هذا الشيء الخاص بي ، استمع إلى ما قلته للتو ،
ولكن بدلاً من ذلك ،
إذا كنت مجرد رسالتك ،
فقد كنت محبوبًا للغاية ، فلن تتمكن
من كتابة القصة
التي نطرحها ، فلن يفعلوا
القصة
حتى لا تصدقوا ذلك
لن يفعلوا
قم بالقصة لأنهم ليسوا كذلك
، لن يفعلوا القصة
لأنهم ضدنا لأنهم
وسائل إعلام ليبرالية ، نعم إذا ذهبت إلى الثعلب
فسوف يكتبون القصة ولا أريد أن أذهب إلى
الثعلب
إنه ممتع للغاية  يعني واحدًا
أن
تسمعها معادية تجاهك تعرف تزيين
البيت الأبيض لعيد الميلاد ،
أنت تعلم بالتأكيد لا أوافق
معك تعرف
فكرة الثعلب بأكملها التي أعنيها للحديث عن الحرب في
عيد الميلاد
، من المضحك أنها
ستقود  هذا
لكن لكن بالتأكيد هو أحد تلك
الأدوار التقليدية
وآه لا أعلم أن حديثها رائع
مثل
أنك تعلم أعتقد أن ميلانيا لديها صراع داخلي
وأنا تعلم أنه عاد إلى الحدود
للحظة أعتقد ذلك  أنت تعلم كأم
أن غرائز الأمومة فيها قد
انطلقت وهي
تهتم حقًا ولكن لا يوجد زوج يذهب
إلى المنزل
لزعيم العالم الحر لمناقشة
ما تشعر به حيال ذلك ،
بغض النظر عن
أنها تقف في الصف وهي  هل تعلم
أنها قررت فقط أن ما سمعته
وما قيل لها
هو ما هي سيادة القانون في
بلدنا ولهذا أعتقد أنك تعلم أننا
نشاهد ديمقراطيتنا تتحول إلى
ديكتاتورية في هذه
المرحلة وهي نوع من الطقوس التي يتم غسل أدمغتها
أنت تعرف أن الناس يواصلون استخدام هذه الكلمة
بشكل فضفاض ولكنك تعلم أن هذا ما
أفكر فيه
وعلى الجانب الآخر ، فأنت تعرف
ميلانيا
أم تقاليد السيدة الأولى
والرئيس قد خرجت من النافذة
مع هذين الزوجين
وأشعر أنه إذا
كنت أعني أن هناك الكثير مما يمكن
القيام به ولكن مرة أخرى
لا يوجد دعم لا يوجد فهم
أم لا ، لذلك لا يمكنها الذهاب إلى الرئيس
والتحدث معه في النهاية ،
فهم لا يجلسون ويتحدثون في
نهاية  اليوم أو تناول العشاء كعائلة
وناقش الأشياء التي تجري ،
لكنك تعلم أنني
أعتقد أن السياسات ستستبعد دائمًا
وأن دونالد هو المسؤول عن
أم ميلانيا مرة أخرى كما
تعلم الشخص الذي لديه المزيد  العاطفة
أم من دونا
يجب أن يعجبني مرة أخرى ما زلت أقول إنه على
وشك
المشي على الخط